kids got stuck in the habit of telling
me where he's going
you can't just bolt out of here first
thing in the morning without giving me
his exact location and up the wood Shire
field that's where we went camping with
Devon it's not a lot of land to conduct
a successful launch
I asked me that the weather balloon
should carry the nearly 120 miles just
scratching the upper atmosphere it's
working we're getting a signal I stopped
by the McTiernan farm on the way back in
town all two dozen of their cows were
found dead since you've watching us now
if we got any calls at this office about
the army have an end to the old base the
local authorities have been notified by
my superiors I'm the only authority in
this town I have been notified of
anything that's impossible
the boys are not here and I don't know
where they are call Robert at the office
we're gonna find him oh my god we made
contact with extraterrestrials do you
know how this changes everything Sean oh
it's gonna be awesome
aliens Sean aliens I don't want the
whole town getting into a panic over
nothing you ready for the show let's do
it
we're going for liftoff in t-minus 10 9
8 7 6
[Music]
you
you